I finished magum in three years at
vanderborg I could earn decent amount of
money at most places graduating like
that I then took a consulting job that
was paid less than most of my other
people were because I could work
directly with the CEO I then gave up on
the Consulting career to do Fitness cuz
that was my kind of entrepreneurial
thing the first move I made is I asked
40 different gym owners if I could work
for them for free I realized that I was
going to be getting more out of the
exchange than the person who I was
working for and so I knew that so I
asked to work free and so he started to
employ me and he eventually started
paying me minimum wage now I would have
to swallow my pride in order to take
that job but it was one of the best
investments I ever made and rather than
compare myself to the people who are
earning more than me and I'm going to be
real with you I did and it hurt but I
felt that long term this was going to be
more aligned with what I wanted to
ultimately do